you're going to be absolutely disgusted
after you hear how evil this company is
this company created a Wonder material
called Teflon that ended up being used
in everything from non-stick pants to
floss the food containers to pizza boxes
popcorn bags everything that we
constantly ate from but what this
company didn't tell the world was that
Teflon is super toxic and that it can
taste forever chemicals that never break
down and that they were dumping these
forever chemicals into the ground to
save money so these chemicals spread
into our water Farms into the animals we
eat and ultimately into us to work today
99.7 of Americans have these forever
chemicals in their bloodstream which is
linked to things like testicular cancer
and kidney cancer before we reveal who
this evil company was all the sound
effects you heard in this short came
from art list the best royalty-free
music and sound effects platform get two
months free with any annual subscription
by clicking the link in the pin comment
and this evil company is Dupont one of
the richest families in America